[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et un plaisir de vous
retrouver dans point de vue avec deux
invités qui ont accepté notre invitation
pour débattre des sujets de l'actualité
la plus brillante et la plus brûlante
aussi bon soir christophe de voogd vous
êtes historien professeur à sciences po
vous enseigner la rhétorique et les
idées politiques
vous êtes aussi le président du conseil
scientifique de la fondapol think tank
de sensibilité libérale dirigé par notre
ami dominique reynié est votre dernier
ouvrage votre participation plus
exactement au dernier ouvrage de la
fondapol démocratie sous tension a été
publié sous la direction de ce même
dominique reynié bonsoir maxime d'égayer
bonsoir vous êtes adjoint au maire du 2e
arrondissement dans le cas présenté mais
fait avant c'est vrai oui mes filles ne
sont pas l'âge et au pardon mais vous
êtes toujours conseiller régional
d'ile-de-france a jusqu'aux prochaines
élections au moins vous êtes toujours le
patron du groupe socialiste et
écologiste hausse même temps les
régionales et vous êtes toujours expert
associé à la fondation jean jaurès voilà
voyez sujet peu évolué quand même et
votre dernier ouvrage la grande des
possessions pour une éthique numérique
européenne a été justement publié par la
fondation jean jaurès parlons si vous le
voulez bien pour commencer d'un projet
de loi qui a été présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres son nom une loi
pour la confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire alors il ya un certain nombre
de mesures qui sont rassemblés dans ce
texte
en voici 2 présenté par eric dupond
moretti le garde des sceaux
on commence par l'article 1 qui prévoit
de filmer les procès à quoi ça sert
écoutez les explications du ministre de
la justice sape pour but quand même on
va le dire parce que ça c'est essentiel
de permettre aux français de mieux
appréhender leur justice ces procès ne
seront diffusés qu'à compter du moment
où ils ont connu leur épilogue
définitive c'est-à-dire à partir du
moment où la sphère est définitivement
jugée mais pourra directement filmer un
procès en appel par exemple comme ça on
saura très vite si un pourvoi en
cassation pas si c'est définitif
et si ça peut être difficile
voilà plus parmi les autres mesures il
ya la généralisation des cours criminel
départemental alors l'idée c'est qu'en
fait une forme de démantèlement
dès que les cours d'assises les cours
d'assises classique avec un jury
populaire continueront à exister mais
pour les crimes susceptibles de moins de
20 ans de prison
ils seront jugés en première instance
par ces cours criminel départemental qui
était déjà en test depuis plusieurs
années et le garde des sceaux s'en
réjouit je renforce la souveraineté du
jury populaire qui était perdu depuis la
mandature de nicolas sarkozy ce projet
de loi revitalise la cour d'assisses
traditionnelle et étant c'est vrai des
cours criminelles dont tous les
indicateurs me disent qu'ils vont vers
une satisfaction de nos concitoyens
alors soyons précis quand le garde des
sceaux dit qu'il renforce sa
souveraineté du jury populaire
ça veut dire que dans les cours
d'assises en fait le poids du jury
populaire sera plus fort par rapport à
celui des magistrats dans la prise de
décision alors il ya d'autres mesures
mais on peut pas toutes les citer il ya
notamment la fin du crédits automatiques
de réduction de peine
est ce que ça vous paraît une d'un bon
projet macri mme desgagnés un bon projet
c'est un projet un peu fourre tout qui
est décalé je crois surtout avec son
ambition première puisque on indique
qu'il veut réinstaurer la confiance
dans l'institution judiciaire est
objectivement je trouve que ça ne répond
pas totalement donc vous l'avez vu il ya
des mesures qui concernent fait de
pouvoir filmer des adaptations qui sont
faites sur les procédures de jugement
mais en réalité je trouve que d'abord
c'est une réforme qui arrive bien tard
dans le quinquennat on est quand même à
la fin du quinquennat
c'est l'une des dernières lois qui
pourrait être agrément je trouve aussi
que c'est une loi qui est décalée avec
d'autres
textes qui sont adoptées notamment en
matière
de justice ou en matière de sécurité est
en réalité je trouve que on voit là
finalement les incapacités du maquereau
nice va pouvoir avoir une vision
d'ensemble de la chaîne pénale de la
chaîne judiciaire
c'est à dire que si on veut vraiment
parler de la confiance dans la justice
et je crois aussi qu'il faut parler tout
à la fois de la police aussi et puis
parler aussi de ce qu'on fait des gens
qui sont en détention
que ce soit en terme de formation que ce
soit en termes et bien d'accès à
l'emploi vous savez que maintenant on ne
compte que 28 % des détenus qui
travaillent alors que sané mans fort de
réinsertion alors que au début des
années 2000 il avait près de la moitié
donc je trouve que c'est un texte qui
est un parfait parce que il ne traite
pas de l'ensemble des problématiques de
la justice est ce que quand dans une loi
christophe devaux qu'il n'y a pas de
mesures phares ou de direction claire ça
veut dire que il ya apparemment de
philosophie derrière
écoutez je crois que c'est ce même pas
l'accabler parce que dia il n'y a pas de
maquereaux nist patenté sur ce plateau
mais je dirais que cette affaire de film
est un peu le symbole de cette loi c'est
à dire on répond quand même par un
élément de comme même au sens noble et
on le voit c'est l'article 1 de montrer
que c'est important c'est exactement ça
mais ce n'est pas d'ailleurs inutile
marfa ça reste quand même 2 de la com on
peut dire et sur pas mal de sujets je
voudrais pas être trop sévère on voit
que souvent le problème au lieu d'être
réglée substantiellement est réglé en
communication alors il règle avec le
talent de d'eric dupond-moretti moi je
les apprécie beaucoup son talent en rond
rhétorique notamment puisqu'il dit un
texte plus lisible plus efficace une
justice plus easy plus efficace plus
accessible mais je crois quand même que
les faut partir du d'avray diagnostic je
dirais qu'elle est quels sont les trois
grands problèmes de la justice en france
c'est son un techno impécuniosité un
manque de moyens je rappelle toujours
que la justice française est le seul
service public qui soit en dessous de la
moyenne européenne alors que vous savez
que pour tout le reste on est à des
millions de kilomètres au dessus des
autres
alors ça ils avaient des efforts la
ministre y fait des efforts il a évoqué
année après année son budget augmente
j'aurais préféré un plan quinquennal oui
ce que je veux dire
la partialité on parle toujours de
l'indépendance et d'ailleurs
à dessein on confond les deux
l'impartialité de la justice est quand
même une vraie question dans l'opinion
publique
on l'a vu avec le processeur cosy on le
voit avec un certain nombre de procès je
dirais de normes aux habituelles en
matière de criminalité
et puis le problème de la responsabilité
donc l'irresponsabilité des magistrats
qui sont quand même
il est vrai dans un état français où la
responsabilité ni politique ni pénale
n'est véritablement cultivées sont quand
même particulièrement loin de toute
responsabilité
donc je crois que tant qu'on aura pas
poser les vrais problèmes de la justice
notamment aux yeux des français
on ne fera un peu que de la littérature
secondaire sur ce sujet je trouve assez
frappant votre intervention que je
rejoins grande partie parce
qu'effectivement ce un texte on va
parler plus de ce qu'il n'y a pas que ce
qu'il y a et je pense que c'est un
signal quand même assez négatif lorsque
vous avez un projet de loi et qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'ils ne répondent pas
qu'ils sont posées je suis assez
d'accord avec vous je rajouterais comme
la question d'indépendance du parquet
comme la grande mesure attendue
depuis de nombreuses années qui
n'apparaît pas encore dans ce texte
alors qu'on sait que on a été la france
a été condamné à de multiples reprises
sur ce sujet là donc c'est effectivement
un texte de circonstance mais qui va pas
très loin sur lequel on a du mal à
trouver en réalité les arrête et qui est
aussi un texte d'adaptation quand on
parle par exemple de l'évolution des
cours d'assises ce que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure on voit bien que le sujet
principal c'est d'abord le les délais
pour de décisions qui sont pris par la
justice et donc l'engorgement des
tribunaux
et donc on essaie de s'adapter on
mettant en place des dispositifs
différents pour essayer d'y répondre
mais sans finalement répondre à la vraie
question qui et comment mais plus de
moyens comment est-ce qu'on organise me
la justice pour lui permettre de rendre
et bien ses décisions de manière plus
rapide et manière plus efficace donc ont
effectivement c'est c'est un texte qui à
mon avis va produire beaucoup de regrets
mais je crois qu un peu par donc un peu
comme pour tous les grands sujets de
réforme de l'état qui a quand même été
un des grands ratés ce quinquennat par
rapport à ses promesses
tous les grands services publics je
pense aux miens à l'éducation notamment
je crois qu'il ya ya ya un deal qui
naquit n'est jamais passé qui a toujours
été ratée en france on l'a vu notamment
à l'époque jospin pardon c'est de
proposer beaucoup plus de moyens
moyennant une restructuration en
profondeur en général on propose soit
moins de moyens soit plus de moyens mais
sans restriction ou l inverse et ça ne
passe pas ça ne peut pas passer ça c'est
vraiment la méthode de la réforme il
faut faire un deal avec avec le corps
judiciaire y compris les avocats au sens
large le monde judiciaire pour dire plus
de moyens mais restructuration radicale
car n'oublions pas la phrase de
montesquieu c'est la quête en libéral
nous séparons la phrase de montesquieu
la justice
il savait de quoi il parlait il était
magistrat lui-même président de tribunal
et bien si la justice elle dispose d'un
pouvoir si terrible dit-il et il faut
donc absolument que ce pouvoir soit
contrôlée c'était un magistrat qui
disait ça et comme on était aux
citations vous souvenez de cet auteur à
peu tombé dans l'oubli qui selon le
le nom de plume était casamayor qui est
un haut magistrat et qui disait tout le
drame de la justice et qu'on a donné le
nom de une vertu à une administration
les internautes s'en assez sévère et
comme vous sur cette réforme la réforme
de la justice proposé par eric
dupond-moretti t le cohérente vous
répondez non à 68% sur twitter vous
pouvez continuer à donner votre point de
vue et puis voici quelques commentaires
celui de dominique ce n'est pas un film
qui va raviver ma confiance
allusion donc au fait que les audiences
seront désormais filmer ma confiance en
la justice ce sont les condamnations et
surtout le maintien des criminels en
prison jusqu'au bout de leurs peines on
ferait mieux de régler le cas des
réductions de peines pour les
délinquants dangereux ajoute nicole
supprimer les jurys populaires ne fera
pas remonter la cote de confiance en la
justice par la population et puis jean
paul qui nous dit la justice sera plus
que jamais couper des attentes des
victimes alors ce qui est vrai c'est que
derrière ces commentaires il ya un
constat qui semble être assez largement
partagé par les français si l'on en
croit ce sondage récent de l'ifop pour
le jdd et sud radio c'est un sondage qui
date de la fin du mois dernier
quand on dit aux français est ce que la
justice est trop laxiste
ils sont 81% à répondre oui
est ce que c'est parce ça le coeur du
problème maxime d'égailler c'est à dire
qu'il ya une justice qu'ils considèrent
qu'elle fait correctement son métier
mais des français qui trouvent qu'elle
n'est pas assez sévère alors d'abord je
pense pas que la justice considère
qu'elle fasse correctement son métier
les magistrats les avocats et bien
généralement exercent dans des
conditions qui sont assez déplorable je
voulais dire sur le fait de rendre des
décisions proportionnée aux délits qui
ont été commis je pense par ailleurs
qu'ils ont raison précisément de leur
manque de moyens des difficultés
quelquefois pouvoir instruire dans de
bonnes conditions l'ensemble des
affaires après sur leur crise de la
question de ce laxisme
vous parliez
vertus tout à l'heure de la justice on
peut aussi parler quelquefois de
fantasmes je ne crois pas moi que ce
soit des mesures laxistes pour le coup
le ministre y est revenu puisque
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui on
va dire fort dans le débat public cette
ce procès en laxisme qui fait à la
justice vous vous apercevez que c'est
pâques à bord les mesures sont prises de
manière de plus en plus de manière de
plus en plus dur par les peines sont de
plus en plus forte pardon ces dernières
années vis-à-vis des délinquants et
d'ailleurs moi g
en tête des sondages du de points de vue
sur les mesures qui étaient prises par
exemple contre un ancien chef de l'état
où on considérait que c'était des
mesures trop dures donc en fait suivant
les affaires on considère que c'est trop
dur autres la mauricie oui sauf mais la
porte là dans le coup ça cogne fort que
non non aux nazis la justice elle doit
être elle doit être la même pour tous et
on s'aperçoit quand même on s'aperçoit
quelquefois de la dureté des mesures
prises lorsque elle touche les gens les
plus connus mais quand vous avez des
gens qui se retrouvent en prison parce
que ils ont volé dans un supermarché ça
n'émeut personne inconsciente et la
terreur à travers la ville attention ne
pensez pas ça parce que précisément
aujourd'hui le problème en france par
rapport aux autres pays européens et qui
d'ailleurs explique pourquoi on a des
taux de récidive qui sont des taux de
récidive important c'est que la seule
réponse qu'apporte l'état et la justice
lorsqu'il y à des délits qui sont commis
c'est précisément d'envoyer en rétention
une partie souvent d'ailleurs pas trop
longtemps c'est vrai mais les gens qui
sont condamnées alors qu'il ya d'autres
possibilités de pouvoir mieux exercer
une peine ça peut être par des mesures
de réparation et c'est surtout par des
mesures de réinsertion et ça aujourd'hui
la france est très en retard vis-à-vis
des autres pays européens et en
l'occurrence le texte de monsieur dupont
moretti ils répondent de manière très
minime
enfin quand même la sphère du voleur
d'orange dans le supermarché faudrait
qu'on en sorte un petit peu c'est vrai
qu'il ya un durcissement des peines qu
un homme très simple c'est une explosion
de la gravité des délits et je crois
qu'ils vous comparer ces deux courbes
deuxièmement les deux affaires on est
aujourd'hui la cour de cassation vient
de déclarer irresponsable
l'assassin de ce rallye me il y à
quelques heures et c'est ça qu'il avait
commis son crime sous son emprise à
l'influent vous imaginez ce que ça veut
dire si ça fait jurisprudence je pense
que ça peut encourager à consommer des
substances si on veut si on a des
desseins criminels non c'est un
véritable problème c'est à dire que ce
genre d'affaires ne passera pas dans
l'opinion
on ne peut pas dire que la cour de
cassation soient débordés par les
urgences se permanente elle vit c'est
son principe tant mieux quand même dans
le temps long judiciaire je vous
rappelle que hier vous avez eu un repris
de justice qui avait été libéré de façon
anticipée qui a commis un viol
extrêmement grave donc
sortons un peu s'il vous plaît du vol d
orange dans les supermarchés ce qui
choque les français je dirais pas ses
pales laxisme comme on dit c'est
l'inéquité c'est-à-dire qu'ils comparent
des verdicts d'accord entre eux des
crimes qui paraissent quand même
disproportionnée à la peine et c'est
seul un qui ne va pas les français ont
le sentiment que la justice
en d'autres termes est injuste et ça je
crois que c'est le bon sens moral du
peuple comme disait raymond boudon qui
qui parle là et on aurait tort notamment
à gauche de ne pas l'écouter c'est à
dire le sentiment qu'il y a deux poids
deux mesures pas forcément vis-à-vis des
puissants ou des faibles mais vis-à-vis
de certains coupables et vis-à-vis
d'autres coupables
et quand vous la faire sarkozy je crois
que ce qui a choqué c'est quand même la
lourdeur de la peine par rapport à des
crimes ultra violents qui sont moins
sanctionnés et ça on ne l'a fait la
démonstration notamment dans les
colonnes du figaro
donc je pense que c'est ce sentiment
d'inéquité si vous le si vous touchez
cette chose fondamentale dans l'esprit
populaire qui pose le plus de problème
je constate
que ce point n'est pas vraiment abordé
par le projet doit sauf la réduction des
peines automatiques
ça pose le problème de la légitimité de
l'institution
voilà moi je pense aujourd'hui que les
attaques qui sont faites sur les mesures
de peine
voilà aujourd'hui je les entends dans le
débat public et je considère
qu'aujourd'hui elles ont peut-être plus
de force qu'avant pas au regard de ce
qui est produit par l'institution
judiciaire parce que moi j'ai tendance à
la respecter mais parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui elle souffre
d'un manque de légitimité et c'est ça le
sujet et c'est ça qu'on attend d'un
gouvernement c'est comment est-ce qu'on
redonne de la légitimité à la justice
pour que les décisions qui soient prises
soient des décisions qui soient
acceptées par tous et ce qui devrait
être le cas parce que moi je ne suis pas
là pour discuter d'une mesure ou d'une
autre je fais confiance
et c'était le tec normalement le le nom
du texte on doit faire on devrait faire
confiance à l'institution judiciaire
et ça c'est on va dire la responsabilité
du gouvernement ça passe par
l'indépendance plus marquée du parquet
ça passe aussi certainement par des
moyens plus importants qui sont donnés à
la justice sa passe enfin par un
meilleur accès aux droits parce que
quand on parle de la justice s'est pas
seulement et bien la façon dont on va
organiser des peines c'est aussi la
façon dont permet à chaque citoyen de
pouvoir accéder à la justice
et là vous parler d'injustice il ya une
injustice dans notre pays c'est
qu'aujourd'hui l'accès au droit et n'est
pas le même pour tout le monde donnait
tout à fait d'accord ternie moi là
dessus oui euh ce dernier mot je
voudrais aussi mentionner quand même
c'est la question que je reviens là
dessus c'est la responsabilité c'est à
dire que vous n'aurez pas de légitimité
si vous n'avez pas d'impartialité et de
responsabilité et ce problème touche
aussi le monde politique où le sait bien
et pour les mêmes raisons le président
république a d'ailleurs récemment
déploré le peu de suites qui sont qui
sont donnés par le conte c'est super de
la magistrature à toutes les requêtes
des français contre l'administration de
la justice se termine avec ce
commentaire de yoann je crains nous dit
il que le film que le fait par don de
filmer des jugements puisse permettre de
les remettre en cause plus facilement
par la suite
et bien sachez johan que ce n'est que
quand les jugements sont définitive
c'est-à-dire après l'appel ou
éventuellement la cassation qu'ils sont
susceptibles d'être diffusée tant que la
procédure judiciaire est en cours il n'y
a pas de diffusion des images nous
changeons de sujet si vous le voulez
bien
pour 1
un thème plus spécifiquement parisien si
vous êtes sur twitter peut être avez
vous vu passer des images avec ce
hashtag saccage paris c'est un mouvement
qui lie à une dizaine de jours et ce
sont des images où on voit l'espace
extérieur parisiens assez fortement
dégradé à la fois par manque de
d'entretien beaucoup de saletés aussi
par l'installation de mobiliers urbains
qui ne fait pas forcément l'unanimité
alors ce mouvement est il justifié
écoutez la réaction de la maire
socialiste de paris anne hidalgo c'était
la semaine dernière sur rtl
pour elle c'est l'extrême droite qui est
à l'oeuvre derrière ce mouvement je
voulais vous dire quand même sur ce qui
s'est passé sur les réseaux sociaux
cette semaine on l'a vu aussi c'est une
méthode assez simple il ya une trop
mobilisation de la vie politique qui est
à l'oeuvre un peu partout y compris en
france et les campagnes de dénigrement
c'est ça plus que campagne de
dénigrement regarder on a pu faire le
décryptage remonter jusqu'aux premiers
hashtag qui a été fait voir quels
étaient les sites les gros comptes
d'ailleurs c'est cool proximité avec
l'extrême droite
christophe devaux un mot sur le la
stratégie de communication de la maire
de paris puisque c'est l'un de vos
domaines d'excellence elle est assez
coutumier du fait d'un que souvent elle
dit à mon m'accuse parce que je suis une
femme
on m'accuse parce que je suis d'origine
immigrée la sai on m'accuse parce que
c'est l'extrême droite qui est à la
manoeuvre c'est à dire que plutôt
dénigrer l'émetteur que de juger
forcément de la pertinence de la taxe
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle en
rhétorique une diversion c'est à dire
qu'on va donc passer du sujet à la
personne est attaquée à 2000m et
toujours ces d'extrême droite d'ailleurs
sans doute que les rats de paris sont
d'extrême droite je pense qu'il n'y a
aucun doute là dessus un g on parlera du
gud je veux créé voilà j'ai été
interrogé et ils ont tous pris leur
carte de rassemblement national
donc c'est tout à fait un des trois un
des trois procédés habituels d'une
partie de la gauche heureusement pas
toute la gauche d'une partie de la
gauche qui est d'une part le déni ça
n'est pas vrai et vous savez que la
mairie de paris a essayé de montrer que
toutes ces photos étaient fausses manque
de chance 99,9 pour cent étaient tout à
fait vrai ensuite quand on peut plus
dire ça n'est pas vrai don c'est
l'extrême droite diversion et puis il ya
le deux poids deux mesures et là encore
on retombe sur le premier sujet c'est
pour ça que guillaume roquette a bien
sûr associé d2 les deux sujets un
problème d'équité
quand vous êtes parisien ce qui arrive à
pas mal de gens finalement ou quand vous
passez à paris vous apercevez que par
exemple si vous les repeindre votre
porte cochère dans une autre couleur
il vous faut je ne sais combien de mois
d'appels de commissions deux sous
commissions et en général pour avoir une
réponse négative et dans mon quartier et
près de mon immeuble j'ai dû donc
repeindre à l'identique ma porte cochère
il y as et un peuple aux shawn jaune vif
est en plus totalement décati qui sont
là depuis le mois d'août au nom du code
vide
c'est ce qu'on appelle les corona piste
c'est à dire son désir air cycliste
balises et des trompes et on la mairie
de paris explique que elle peut pas les
faire
définir autrement puisque ils sont
provisoires non là il s'agit des plots
jaunes c'est autre chose a parlé mais
vous parlez des blocs de béton
je suis cycliste je peux vous dire que
les blocs de béton fort dangereux
d'ailleurs où très souvent vous devez
faire très attention à pas tomber soit
sur le bloc soit sur le cycliste d'en
face non là je parle des plots jaunes
qui se sont là en fait pour empêcher le
stationnement
c'est des plots qui nous des lignes qui
ne mènent nulle part a nulle part et qui
sont par exemple en plein coeur de paris
vous en avez des rues entières
c'est absolument alors là c'est pas une
question de goût c'est totalement une
esthétique et dans une couleur qui sema
confusion n'est pas une couleur
répertoriés par les monuments
historiques le jaune vif étant pas
vraiment une couleur de la capitale et
bien ça c'est là la mairie encore une
fois la preuve présentée sous forme pour
lutter contre le coc vite j'ai toujours
pas compris en quoi cette étude lutte
contre le coc ville depuis on a retiré
la lutte contre le coc vide et c'est
toujours là de plus en plus détériorée
et avec cette chose qui moi en fait je
crois qu'il ya une question philosophie
derrière ça c'est cette idée parce que
ce sont des gens très bien cette idée
très rousseauiste que tout le monde est
merveilleux tout le monde est bon et
tout le monde se réjouir à des
innovations dans la capitale par exemple
ce que j'appelle le syndrome du
récipient vous avez vu qu'on met des
réceptions pour tous et partout des
réceptions sanitaire souhait ce que je
veux dire
on met des récipients pour les fleurs
des récepteurs pour les ordures et
récipients pour tous et on hamm est
absolument partout mais qu'est ce qui se
passe quand vous mettez un récipient
quel qu'il soit dans une grande ville
dans une métropole
ça devient une déchetterie dans la
minute mais on dirait que la mairie de
paris n'a jamais réfléchi aux
conséquences de ses actes dans une
métropole où il est vrai les gens sont
un civil et ça a toujours existé et avec
dans une métropole où si fréquentées que
paris c'est encore plus le cas
et donc on a nos récipient mais regardez
bien dans les dans sa cage parlez vous
verrez énormément de représentation de
sa dune de jeu c'est pas 2 destiné à
recevoir des fleurs destinées à recevoir
des arbres destinés à est en fait
destinée qui reçoivent en fait des
tombereaux d'ordures et vous savez que
c'est une inférence et puisque demain le
15 avril nous allons fêter
la naissance d'eugène poubelles qui est
né le 15 avril 1931 qui était donc
préfet de paris et qui avait imposé des
systèmes qu'on appellera plus tard des
poubelles sur des boîtes en bois de 80
ou 120 litres et les parisiens étaient
furieux parce qu'il avait fallu on a
acheté que ça va coûter cher alors
maxime des gayets vous n'êtes plus
adjoint au maire du 2e arrondissement de
paris mais est ce que vous êtes toujours
socialiste et est-ce que vous souhaitez
anne hidalgo sur cette affaire
d'ailleurs au passage puisque vous
parlez de poubelles à paris à une
poubelle tous les 300 mètres
d'ailleurs vous considérez que ça fait
trop de récipients en réalité c'est
évidemment nécessaire pour le pas et de
la propreté
vous parlez de diversion tout à l'heure
et moi je suis un peu en colère avec ce
débat là parce que c'est un débat
effectivement qui est motivée par des
diversions puisqu'on veut en faire un
sujet politique
alors qu'en réalité la question de la
propreté c'est une question sérieuse qui
normalement devrait pas faire l'objet de
caricaturer de batailles politiciennes
comme c'est le cas depuis quelques
semaines et mois là je suis énervé sur
ce sujet là sur la façon dont
précisément on a organisé une diversion
alors que c'est une problématique qu'une
pratique auxquels sont confrontés tous
les maires de toute la france qui ont
des difficultés effectivement assurée et
bien un minimum de propreté dans l'élite
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont une
difficulté
d'abord parce que les gens ça disent
mais je le disais c'est une affaire bien
plus intéressante est bien plus sérieuse
si on veut ça marche pas si les autres
dhainaut nos auditeurs pourront
s'intéresser aux enjeux de propreté mais
c'est une question qui partent
clairement intéressante dans le monde
dans lequel on vit
ce qui s'est passé ces dernières années
à paris et ce qui se passe dans beaucoup
de métropole c'est qu'il ya une
transformation des usages de l'espace
public ça vous a pas échappé
les gens mangent plus facilement dehors
on a d'ailleurs aménagé la ville ça
c'est vrai pour permettre que et bien
les gens passent plus de temps dans des
parcs
on a même fait les berges sur la scène
donc les berges sur la scène quand vous
avez des gens qui s'y baladent ça peut
évidemment produire toute une série
d'effets induits qui sont le fait que
vous avez un usage différent de la ville
et donc vous allez et bien quelquefois
une partie du matériau humain qui peut
être plus abîmées ou des détritus ce
qu'ils sont là alors qu'il n'était pas
là auparavant parce que c'est ce à quoi
pourquoi on n'y a pas pensé à ça je vous
dis aujourd'hui quand vous avez airbnb
pour vous parliez du 2e arrondissement
moi je vois les dégâts de airbnb sur la
façon dont le deuxième est propre ou pas
propre parce que évidemment la façon
dont les touristes comporte n'est pas
identique à celle à la façon dont les
habitants se comporte la faim depuis
maintenant un mois - tu aurais je suis
d'accord avec vous est pris n'est pas
plus près donc
et donc un sujet aujourd'hui c'est
comment est-ce que ces dix nouveaux
usages de la ville on arrive à s'assurer
du fait que eh bien il est trop duyse le
moins de détritus ce possible ça c'est
une question intéressante et quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe dans beaucoup
de métropole vous apercevez que c'est
une vraie difficulté c'est par vous il
n'ya pas de responsabilité de la mairie
de paris ce jeudi
jeudi et vous l'avez vous l'avez
remarqué justement que il ya une
évolution aujourd'hui de l'usaj de
l'espace public qui est positive et qui
forcément produit un certain nombre de
problèmes notamment des preuves de
proposer mais aussi d'autres types de
nuisances et des nuisances sonores et on
a eu l'occasion d'ailleurs d'en parler
sur ce plateau donc la ville elle évolue
alors j'entends que certains veulent en
faire des villes musées nous à paris on
considère qu'il faut être en capacité
d'accompagner tout ça pour limiter le
type de ce type de nuisance
alors vous m'indiquer un instant que et
bien à paris
on voyait - r bienne be vous avez raison
mais la pandémie a fait fuir les
touristes mais la pandémie a aussi des
impacts sur l'organisation des services
publics aujourd'hui vous avez 10 % de
personnel en moins pour nettoyer les
oreilles à paris parce que comme toute
une série de services
vous avez des gens qui se retrouvent en
incapacité de pouvoir travailler parce
que cas contact extérieur donc ça c'est
une réalité
troisième sujet que je voulais évoquer
avec vous c'est que paris a mais les
moyens donc moi je ne nie pas qu'il ya
des sujets de propreté mais on n'en fait
pas un sujet de polémique aujourd'hui on
a multiplié on a multiplié les moyens on
a financé pour essayer de pouvoir y
répondre et j'appelle aussi au fait
qu'il ya un minimum de civisme avoir
alors dans ce débat qui n'est pas un
débat sur le fond parce que là on aurait
capacité à pouvoir discuter de manière
sereine et intelligente
c'est un débat sur le procès des
socialistes et de la ville de paris sur
la sur la transformation de la vie
d'ailleurs et ce qui est amusant de voir
intéressante et je le stigmatise pas et
j'en terminerai par là ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on a et d'ailleurs
les adjoints qui étaient attaqués ont pu
considérer qu' il y avait un côté de
mauvaise foi parce que c'était des
images anciennes qui est émis pour une
partie d'entre elles moi je pense que
c'est assez intéressant aussi c'est que
les gens d'une certaine manière vive sur
une vision idéalisée de la ville et je
pense que là dessus on est un peu à côté
de la plaque et qu'une fois de plus ce
sont les stratégies politiciennes qui
aujourd'hui on a fait des pubs de mal
juste juste un mot je passe le stade là
en passant parce que c'est important
vous savez que nos internautes se
passionnent pour ces sujets que nous
évoquons chaque jour la mairie de paris
at elle contribué au ca car il faudra
mettre sa cage entre guillemets mais
c'est parce que c'est le nom du hashtag
saccagé la capitale oui à 84% ya quand
même quelque 15% des gens qui
considèrent que l'on n'a pas forcément
de responsabilité libre qui peut être un
ami politique de christophe de voogd
avec un pseudo pareil je suis à paris
depuis maintenant quinze ans la ville
s'est dégradé à tous les niveaux elle
est l'ombre d'elle-même et la mairie de
paris on est responsable c'était la plus
belle ville du monde se maintenant une
poubelle nous dit bastien
jean paris est une fête n'a jamais
signifié qu'il ne fallait pas nettoyé le
lendemain le patrimoine est délaissé au
profit de parisiens irresponsable donc
là la responsabilité partagée
selon notre internaute et puis pm je
suis guide conférencier du patrimoine
c'est un véritable désastre de faire
visiter paris sur cet argument
christophe de voc que vous qui êtes
sensibilité libérale que c'est la
responsabilité individuelle de chaque
parisien de faire un peu plus attention
à ce que c'est vrai quand même dû
laisser aller regarder le double
diversion rhétorique pour parler comme
la mairie de propreté
alors que sur le saccage de paris je
parlais de mes plus aux jaunes ça n'a
rien à voir avec le comportement des
parisiens évoquant même être de temps en
temps traiter les sujets donc un
problème de mobilier urbain
d'aménagement de l'espace le massacre
d'un nombre d'arbres considérable je
pense que paris va fournir bordeaux en
bois mort abondamment prochainement cela
par exemple la mairie ne répond jamais
sur son question vinaros et dont elle
n'aurait pas un plant plus dark nourrir
les plantes je sais pas ou parce que je
peux vous dire que la place de la
république que je connais bien il y en a
plus un bon et donc non mais attendez
rappeler de la place de la république
d'avril aménagements qui a apprécié par
les parisiens et par ailleurs les
parisiens ils ont aussi dit ce qu'ils
ont pensé lors des dernières élections
municipales il a donné on peut s'en
remettre aussi maintenant aller aux
militants pour cent oui afin dé 20 %
qu'on votait et et tous n'ont pas voté
pour madame hidalgo pour ces procès
raisons précises mais là vous faites une
diversion deuxièmement il n'est pas
accessible parce que c'est faux de dire
que c'est une campagne d'extrême droite
je vous rappelle l'élu oui c'est
l'argument que les algues au caylar du
mandat ni l'alcool et je dis pas ça
j'avais repris par politisation vous
avez joué les regarde et mutilent suis
libre c'était par nova j'avoue c'est
peut-être un dommage à valérie pécresse
quand libre le monsieur libre nous
explique que c'est terrible et que paris
est une poubelle je crois que c'est
grosso modo loge je pense pas
la ville s'est dégradé à tous les
niveaux très bien les transports en ile
de france vous vous prenez un peu les
transports en commun bon est ce que vous
considérez qu'aujourd'hui transports en
commun sont propres mais alors vous êtes
de la politisation
c'est ce que j'aime et loisirs une perf
à raison de 3 non je vous en fais une
illustration c'est que là dessus par
contre personne ne dit ça c'est et ça
c'est pas la mairie de paris c'est la
région de jijel moi j'essaie valashu
vendetta g beaulieu et ils ont le mieux
qui avait 10 ans mahmoud abbas allez
allez pour le coup dans l'est sur les
quais de métro vous allez voir le
résultat
donc rappelleront jeu est un sujet je
rappelle juste que libres auxquelles
vous faites sept mots que le feu des
lions c'est aussi le nom du parti oui
par valérie pécresse précédemment de la
région ile de france voilà et donc on
peut se renvoyer les uns les autres je
peux dire aujourd'hui que si les
transports sont dégoûtants c1 c'est une
responsabilité et un échec
supplémentaire de valérie pécresse
objectivement je n'ai pas besoin de ça
comme un échec supplémentaire donc ça
gérer les bazars ça pour pour parler son
bilan mais ou alors on considère que
c'est une chose sérieuse et dans ces cas
là effectivement on considère qu'il ya
des évolutions des usages qui nécessite
pour des questions de propreté
eh bien on essaye d'améliorer les choses
c'est ce que je crois sont la majorité
des maires c'est ce que je crois fait la
ville de paris et donc pour revenir à
votre propre au premier quand vous dites
aujourd'hui il ya une diversion moi je
dis juste qu'il ya une
instrumentalisation qui fait briller
mais voilà qui mérite sa part à mon avis
un peu mieux ça s'appelle la politique
et enfin je vous invite quand même
permis qu'elle a voyagé à voyager dans
d'autres métropoles d'aller à londres
d'aller à amsterdam ou vérité de
métropole infiniment plus propre me
maryse part de paix s'ils veulent aller
en france ils mettront pas dans une
ville qui le passionnait trop pole mais
quand même deux jeunes filles ce
substantiel à les y aller à cannes vous
verrez comment ces tenues est bien merci
sur cette proposition d'aller dans la
ville de david lee stable - on parle de
plus en plus à droite néo this allons
mettre fin à cette émission merci à tous
les deux dit avoir participé merci à
vous surtout de la reverser 10 et puis
reviendra demain sur figaro live à la
même heure bonsoir
[Musique]